if you had advice that you could give 40
year old Dave would you tell him hey
guys on this episode that for Moses I'm
gonna be flying down to Nashville to
record a full podcast with Dave Ramsey
I'm going to be breaking down a viral
clip we posted that went crazy
everywhere we're gonna be doing a full
workout together and we'll wrap it up
with a photo shoot enjoy
what flavor is that no idea you never
know could be a secret there's no
chocolate chips
problem with white chocolate
not for me travel interrupts my
productivity more than Layla's for me
like having my stuff and my setup I tend
to be more effective when I'm at home
and so it feels like a bigger cost for
me so I try and do it as little as I can
going out to see Dave was something that
like I've always been a big fan of his
stuff and so it made a ton of sense for
me to take a day to fly out see him to
everyone who doesn't fly private I will
give you a little bit of insight and
it's not always as cracked up as you
might think because the Wi-Fi is slow as
[__] yeah we're cheap private jet Flyers
we have limits I just like can't yeah
faster and they just pay obscene amounts
for the plane and like it's just like I
don't want to pay triple the price just
to have like a nice plane like for us
the big thing speed that's what we like
about it I'm still not loaded
waste the [__] time
all right make some goddamn content what
[Music]
I want to hear about Solomon's Paradox
yeah it's almost an ancient King in the
Bible that he was considered one of the
wisest men of all time it's his
particular Paradox because he made lots
of bad decisions repeatedly had
uncontrolled passion for money and women
and neglected to instruct his only son
who went on to ruin his kingdom people
give significantly better advice about
their own scenarios if they don't know
it's about themselves if you only just
filed your own advice it'd be way better
than you currently are a practice that I
started doing which is I have a coaching
session with myself weird I have a
conversation with my future self who's
85 and I asked him for advice on what I
should do now and so 85 year old me
explains to me what I already know in my
deep self but my emotional self that's
you know running the ship forgets but
instead of like meditating to myself I
actually write it down actually like the
judicism
we'll wait for the Wi-Fi
Solomon projects my line and then their
line and then my line again as I'm going
through it so it's like I'm like
chatting but I'm filling out both sides
of the chat but I'm putting different
hats on that's like me talking to me
like I deal with this [__] too I talk
about thinking long and being patient
it's because every day I'm impatient
it's fun I'm like why is this happening
faster like this should have happened
two quarters ago like the same things
that you guys feel as entrepreneurs like
I feel them too
oh wow
I don't know that's like
I'm bigger like what can I control what
can I not control I hope that there was
going to be Wi-Fi and there wasn't good
Wi-Fi I knew I was gonna basically have
three hours of my life taken from me we
ended up turning it into a recording
session which ended up doing really well
from the stuff that we recorded in that
time period so it ended up being a net
positive that I didn't have Wi-Fi if I
had had Wi-Fi the Avante moment might
not have ever been captured so you wanna
hear about Avante Layla and I walk a lot
and so we get stopped fairly frequently
but this particular guy came up to me
didn't say hi and immediately started
telling me about his life and he didn't
take a breath he was like shaking he's
like dude he's like I'm just so sick of
being poor man he's like I've got a
one-year-old I'm working two jobs she's
like so I just I don't know how to get
ahead this is a video I'm making for
Avante the young man who was working two
jobs with a one-year-old who's
struggling and said he was sick and
tired of being poor and didn't know how
to get out there are far more people who
are struggling than there are people who
are succeeding and so having content
that speaks tactically to what to do
when you're in that situation appeals to
a much broader audience it wasn't
surprising me that it got the response
that it did but I'm happy that I think
it served a lot more people than just
Devonte
all right where's the right button here
it's like six buttons here someone
definitely has hit that button
I think a lot of people beat up on Dave
because of his stances on debt I live a
hundred percent debt free but also his
argument succinctly put is that
introduces risk risk when compounded
over a lifetime is bound to come due if
you plan on playing the game for a very
long time you're betting on the fact
that you're never gonna have a bad
season and that's a hard bet to make
have fun thanks wish me luck
if your plan requires luck to succeed
it's a bad plan
people travel all over the country come
here just say you know their debt-free
that's what worked it out so I think
you're going to be right here today's uh
oh good that's my good side yeah
this is usually my better side but uh
thank you for having me honored to have
you sir
you did a podcast with graham Stefan and
he showed you his Investment Portfolio
you said something to him that massively
changed the direction of how we invested
just so you know rich people always
enamored me like I thought they had some
kind of special sauce or something there
aren't any secrets I find something that
they like and that they understand and
that they're good at and they do it a
lot your giftings are much more in the
real estate world than they are in
analyzing stocks if we were going to put
a portfolio together of your knowledge
base it would be 80 real estate 20
stocks maybe probably it's okay if your
portfolio is real estate heavy the
reason that that little piece of advice
that you gave to Graham was so
meaningful for me was because everybody
told me what they did and what had
worked for them I talked to probably
every guy that I know was who was richer
than me and was like what should I do
with all this and the answers that I got
were as different as there are people
under the sun yup left me more confused
than anything when I looked at that pie
and thought okay well what's my
knowledge base it's all business I
showed that clip to Layla my wife and I
was like I think this is what we should
do I think we should just stick to
business and just buy businesses and
grow them that's what we did with
acquisition.com
put money in stuff you understand and
you love don't put money in stuff
because it sounds fancy I'll bring us
home because I had a and I could talk to
you all day if you had advice that you
could give 40 year old Dave would you
tell him you know now that you didn't
know that
play incremental long ball don't look
for the home run I keep waiting for
somebody to call me and for this to get
easy one phone call and it's all over oh
now I don't have to think about it
anymore someone else is going to do it
for me it's all automatic now we're
gonna be automatics never gonna be easy
it's a hustle and grind it's a claw
you're going to make a bazillion
mistakes make mistakes that are
experiments that you survive you put out
a hypothesis you survive the experiment
to live another day to have another
experiment put out another hypothesis
another product that fails another idea
that fails our failures at Ramsey are in
number and in money are way greater than
our successes the only thing is we
survive them a we didn't have debt and B
we never bet the farm on one horse and
so we're not looking for the singular
home run we're looking to survive and
fight another day and keep iterating the
accumulated value of those iterations
are what we call the gleaming mountain
of success which turns out as a pile of
garbage and mistakes that you're just
standing on rather than laying under it
I didn't understand brand I didn't get
it like with Jumanji was just all
quantitative like it was all clicks
conversions like that was all I kind of
cared about going to the content world
was kind of an experiment I'd done
Affiliates I've done referral programs
I've done paid ads I've done cold
outbound but I'd never done content I'd
never made it and then in making content
you learn about brand I'm not saying I
understand brand but I know more than I
did it feels like once you start doing
that you realize that what you were
doing all before was wrong
what's going on dudes I always like
thinking like let me see if I can
download any lessons if someone's making
more money than me there's always
something to learn I would say having a
conversation with with Dave like it's
just showing up he does three hours a
day every single day for 30 plus years
three hours a day I've shown up and
making content he's 62. once you have
the right strategy it's volume like you
just need to do more but I think just
seeing that level of consistency over 30
years like I'm grateful that I passed my
10-year Mark but I'm I'm excited for
what the next 20 looks like that's very
cool
by like and talking or presenting I
think I burn more calories your brain is
25 of your calorie tank and it consumes
like most of your sugar but Coca-Cola
will kill you
except Warren Buffett still murdering it
freaking regular Cherry Pope unlike Two
by The World of Coke and keep it
company wait for it wait for it and
we're not dead
one more flight in the books of not
dying
is it Saturday
oh good I gotta get a good pump on
before I go
foreign
good all right so we're gonna do
I'll be a super set of
calves and hamstrings
with Blum owner of Raw Fitness I will
train way harder if I'm training with a
training partner I'll train longer I'll
do more reps I'll do more sets just
someone else holding me accountable and
one of the nice things if you ever get
the opportunity is to train with someone
stronger than you just like you have
limiting beliefs in business you also
have limiting beliefs in in lifting and
so when you see someone warm up with
your one rep max it really shifts the
way you see the weight gotta start with
calves
start with the most important body part
Cavs were actually my weakest body part
for a very long time and I actually had
a girlfriend say why don't you train
your calves and I've been training them
for like three years so Blum and I have
known each other for 11 years 12 years
Palomas was the gym owner who had a gym
I did not have a gym you lived in one
yeah I would just basically harass
everyone have them let me just come
around a little clipboard and just take
notes on everything they were doing I'm
like Alex is the same Alex he would
always be there asking questions that I
had no answers to
What's your turn what's your this and
I'm like I don't know I'm 29 years old
and I run a gym I don't know what you're
even talking about I'm like what's your
onboarding process he's like they sign
up and then they work
foreign
[Music]
about your legs
apart then I'll do your shoulders
and then I'll do back hard don't do arms
science
so I try in full body every day because
I want to grow everything every day and
I also have a irregular schedule so I
don't want to be like Mondays back day
Wednesday's leg day you know Friday
shoulder tricep bicep and then like I
missed two Fridays in a row and I
haven't trained shoulders bicep tricep
in like three weeks so I train
everything every day bodybuilding and
business are actually really similar in
that you will have uneven inputs to
create an even output because perfect
business would have amazing marketing
amazing sales amazing product amazing
customer success but the individual
might be like I'm really good at
marketing and that's all I do and that's
fine but the business needs to be
balanced and so I kind of think of the
exercises in the same way of like I'm
only going to select exercises and I'm
going to order them and do the most
volume on the ones that I need to work
on the most so that my physique overall
is more balanced you know I think
splitting your muscles typical brochure
you're doing the gym if you just prepare
biceps
all right so that was our workout
[Music]
so we are heading to a photo shoot main
reason if you've ever seen any of my
other random images that have been taken
the reason I'm not wearing a hat is
because when we took the photo shoot
last time we were in transition on the
logos and I didn't want to take a bunch
of pictures of the old logo hat now
we'll have photos once again with the
right logo and the hat and the uh the
logo beater and the logo beater
essential detail cookies ordered some
cookies is that there's no one skips
dessert on the table Yeah nowhere
whatever
fireable effects oh it's honestly yeah
we saw you take the Brownie and slide it
into the trash can after you've done
your lunch didn't take the extra bite uh
what's the deal here I'm not accusing I
just won't understand why
you never know when you're gonna need
one sugar a little sugar well uh oh he's
up
I haven't washed my head since the gym
it's good for your immune system people
will do is we'll run through all the
different facial expressions that we use
for the thumbnails
all the different flannels so we'll just
bash those out
[Music]
I know a lot of you guys are like man
you know what made me really like Rosie
better that's completely crushed
[Music]
it's a bit of a girl post
oh Fortress White
you want to listen to feedback from the
audience but you don't want the feedback
from the audience to change your brand
because Brand's your is your identity
it's your reputation what makes you you
and if you get funneled into like the
algo hole of looking like exactly every
other person who funnels for the
algorithm then you lose the uniqueness
of what makes you you and then you get
the views but then the moment that your
type of content no longer is in Vogue
and something else is like your entire
brand disappears overnight I missed the
others from Garrix I think it was really
good you are your own Niche everyone has
multiple facets they just don't express
them like I like eating dessert I also
look kind of Jack I also am into
business I also work with my wife it's
just like people who [__] with any of
those things and [__] with my stuff but
if it was like challenges are really
important that's all we should make yeah
then I would be catering to something
that's not me don't let me get too far
[Music]